[Musique]
je
plus
[Musique]
alors pour quelle raison fait ça la
bonne raison moi les problèmes étaient
au début j'ai commencé la musculation je
t'écris des tricheurs j'étais pas venu
spécialement faire la musculation comme
compétition de haut niveau ajouté j'ai
connu ou grossir un peu à ce moment là
j'ai commencé à apprendre la pouteille
le sida midi mais j'ai jamais rolko où
c'est un bon sens non non non c'est toi
laurent se procurer ce mauvais pas et
bien certainement pour la même raison
pour laquelle vous faites votre métier
ouais c'est à dire par passion parce que
tous à bout comme ça c'est très
impressionnant
à quel âge avait commencé à faire ça moi
je vais très très jeune qui commence à
l'âge de ces genres ouais mon père
adoptif déjà à la constitution et moi je
faisais à ce moment-là 35 kg a été formé
en personne mais quand vous avez que ça
ça fait huit ans que toi moi ces quatre
en quatre ans donc cela vite finalement
quand même temps vous êtes assez que
c'est parce qu on essaye de faire les
choses bien
il n'aime pas perdre de temps il faut
faire ça tous les jours
tous les jours il parce que pour les
femmes bon c'est pas difficile d'avoir
des muscles à leurs impôts non c'est
vraiment un moment très poussive alors
on est obligé de faire piquer à trois
heures d'entraînement par jour ou plus
chaud pareil pour toi laurence et toute
l'année il n'y a pas deux pas trois mois
d'interruption
quinze jours pour le repos et psychique
et musculaires et en attaque mais vous
trouvez enfin je sais pas c'est au
départ l'idée c'était vous aimiez ça
mais je trouvais ça plus sexy ou vous
trouviez ça sent le mieux c'est quelque
chose de sexy way et l'absence de grèce
c'est beaucoup plus félin plus sensuel
c'est rare en plus non il y avait déjà
beaucoup de filles qui font ça dans le
monde je croyais là combien y en a
beaucoup
hélas beaucoup beaucoup souffert
l'amérique à bord ni si beaucoup plus
d'évoquer à ce moment là le culturisme à
berlin mais en france petit à petit ça
commence à développer parce que c'est un
sport
les gens jouent du point de l'ampleur
enfin on n'est pas obligé de faire du
bodybuilding pour devenir comme ça je
vous dis on peut le faire simplement
pour se mettre en forme et c'est un
travail
oui c'est un travail intense pour nous
parce que nous on y en ait en fait de la
compétition alors ni trop ni on a envie
d'aller beaucoup plus loin chaque jour
ccif ouais faut pour ce sport pour la
compétition et si vous vous arrêtez
qu'est ce qui se passe je vous arrêter
net
c'est vrai que ça devient un indien
c'est à dire qu'on a peu flasque
je pense qu'on aurait du mal à arrêter m
ouais parce que quand on arrive au top
niveau n'a surtout pas envie de
redescendre ouais du corps était si vous
arrêtez un jour toutes les infos
d'arrêter progressivement quoi
l'alimentation est important et dans la
vie quotidienne ça se passe comment
quand vous sais pas quand vous
rencontrez des gens comme ça et qui voit
que vous n'êtes plus baraqué que les
filles normales savons pas si sûr que
les gens se retournent les gens soit au
mr tourner
au même titre que si si on voyait par
exemple une formule 1 dans paris bon
c'est à dire que les voitures de série
ainsi la médaille d'or et on voit une
formule à damparis on se tourne
est ce que ça vous donne de la forte est
ce que si on se
pour frapper ou s'est uniquement
expliquée dire que l'esthétique avant
tout on ne développe pas la force la
force elle suit ouais alors que pour les
sports de force on la développe mais aux
dépens des de l'esthétisme alors que
l'esthétique bombe à la force elle suit
avec
oui tu es satisfait lionel bah moi je
sors excuse à changer vos relations avec
les hommes par exemple dire de quelle
manière la mort lorsqu'un bob je réalise
comme vous déshabiller d'après ce que
est ce que c est différent par rapport à
ce qui se passait avant lorsque vous
n'avez pas ce corps qui donne très tenté
pour une femme
non pas du tout à dire que moi chaise
fait quatre ans que j'entraîne ont pas
vraiment longtemps et je suis je suis
avec le même homme depuis alors je fais
tes aurait pas de projet je fais pas
bien répondre à votre question ce serait
plutôt la ville de morag on nettoie
mois-ci pareil c'est à dire qu'on fait
ça accroche des mecs loi jacques les
mecs veulent plus partir à point si ne
c'est pas ça va pour les deux filles
attirées par quelqu'un d'entier un beau
physique est tombé normale et dans le
milieu je vis
je n'ai apprécié chez plutôt attiré par
un gars qui fait de la musculation et
québec et pdg pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y
mettez un peu de bleu